well as crime climbs in big cities
across the country congresswoman
congresswoman alexandria ocasio-cortez
is blaming the police not the accused
criminals after the nypd arrested 12
shoplifters for stealing diapers and
other household items she tweeted it's
much easier to frame people who steal
baby formula and medicine as monsters to
be jailed then acknowledge our
politics and economic priorities create
conditions where people steal baby
formula to survive and in california
embattled los angeles county district
attorney george gascon announcing
revisions to one of his most
controversial soft on crime policies
that banned prosecutors from seeking
life sentences and filing cases against
minor offenders in adult court now he
says a new committee would review cases
involving minors accused of murder and
other violent crimes to possibly move
the cases to adult court
yeah you know tyrus i have to go to you
what are your thoughts on aoc slamming
the police
i have one thing to say about aoc
who
voted for this individual
that's it
back to you
[Laughter]
i mean i'll tell you her tweet itself
was quite wordy but what do you make of
it the fact that you know when you have
people who are committing crimes theft
and their theft ultimately does rise
prices for other people who are going in
to buy these exact same items baby
formula you know what what is it when
she doesn't talk about the fact that
there is a crime being committed and the
consequences of that
well that's because she doesn't live in
the really real world and there's no
consequences in the woke agenda and
socialism there's no consequences and
here's the thing the people who are
stealing it they're not stealing it
because they got children at home
they're stealing it because they're
selling it they're stealing as much as
they can in mass quantities and they're
going to bodegas and online and ebay and
facebook and they're selling it so she's
100
again
who voted for this individual
back to you well someone who does live
in the real world jackie does i can tell
you that and crime in new york city
through february 13 is up 46 from 2021.
jackie talk to us about what you're
seeing with crime in new york city it's
been brutal nicole and just to make a
point on aoc you know i don't know why
she would think that people are stealing
the baby formula because they need it
the democrats are giving everybody money
for everything they should be able to
just go out and buy it i think tyrus
makes a good point about that but with
respect to what i've been seeing on the
ground here i have watched this city
crumble in the last two years and i've
been out since day one of the pandemic
watching this happen it's actually
gotten worse since eric adams has come
in in my opinion with respect to the
things that i've seen
i have stories of friends telling me
that they've been punched on the subway
needing stitches nobody wants to go down
there i was walking near central park
the other day and a homeless man exposed
himself to me and told me to have a nice
day this is the kind of thing that
you're seeing all the time you've got
homeless mentally ill people are scared
they're not going to come back to work
here unless somebody cleans up the
streets and i think eric adams wants to
do it but he can't do it alone so he's
got a district attorney alvin bragg
that's in his way and i think when the
new york governor's race comes up it's
going to be a big issue because the
governor has the power to remove that
person and help with this situation it's
the only way to get things back up and
running
well raymond you know they continue to
say well these are minor offenses and
then we'll throw up this mug shop this
gentleman james langdon was arrested
three times in a 24-hour period but how
do we keep letting this happen and what
will this lead to if we can continue to
shut away or you know turn a blind eye
to these quote-unquote lesser crimes
well jackie just nailed it the da's
across the country are the heart of the
problem they are failing to prosecute
these crimes and when you say coming
into office as george gascon has in la i
will not prosecute these lower offenses
if you shoplift it's okay i'm going to
look the other way we don't want mass
incarceration guess what you get
metastasized crime that's why you have
walgreens shutting down in california
and then you go back to new york again a
d.a looking the other way for these
petty crimes meanwhile you have
neighborhoods without right aids without
on the upper east side rite aids on 8th
avenue closing down these are major uh
lifelines for people in these
communities and it's not just oh aoc you
know there's jean valjean stealing a
piece of bread they're taking things to
fence on the street and when you protect
criminality you get more of it so we've
got to look to these da's and those
races should be closely watched by the
voters
well the true repercussions i believe
will really come with time
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else